the secret service has concluded its
investigation into a bag of booger sugar
found in the Biden White House and
concluded that they cannot identify any
suspect according to the Secret Service
despite combing through security systems
and indexing several hundred individuals
who entered the West Wing The West Wing
which is perhaps the single most
surveilled and secure place on planet
Earth the investigators were unable to
find any fingerprints that of course was
the investigator's first mistake if you
want to identify the owner of some
Cartagena nose candy you don't check for
fingerprints you check for nostril
Prints but regardless Hunter's nose is
currently scrounging like a pig for
truffles to find the next foreign
Shakedown to score another 10 percent
for the big guy